I hope Aldo Jones does a weird trailer
of this and just throws Meg from Family
Guy Brian how you doing there reject
nation my name is Greg Alba and I'm John
I'm gonna take on a Megalodon to die I
have been looking forward to a trailer
for this movie
jerks I used to have a Megalodon idea
movie who is gonna be like a terrible
version of Jaws starring Taylor Lautner
as a lifeguard who has to take on the
makeup you told was gonna be great but
Jason Statham is a little bit better go
ahead so check this out and patron and
the day shout-out for JT cuz he lives
near the waters that's really fast Wow
some kind of future SeaWorld we're
looking at here or something what a
place to be playing
Oh
clinickers it's a joke Wow
well that is that's kind of terrifying
[Laughter]
so maybe laDawn Rainn Wilson there we go
finally a fun town oh no people
he looks heroic it's kind of got a
negative attitude
[Music]
[Music]
man shark movies are in these days are
they not I cannot wait to check this
this soon to be horrible movie this
looks like a not as good version of like
piranha 3d all I know is that I've
wanted to see a Megalodon movie for
quite some time now I used to be
obsessed with the super Croc and a
Megalodon and this is the exact kind of
movie starts out in their futuristic
underground space aquatic laboratory and
then all of a sudden is Jason Statham
gonna maybe memories like a marine
biologist or something like that I don't
know I read an article on this months
ago now I was like okay this is this is
my dream fourteen-year-old boy my issue
with films like this is when you just
get the tone wrong everything else could
be whatever I movies like this I just
throw a logic way out the window and I
just sit back and enjoy the ride my only
issue that have this is you got two very
different tones in the trailer yeah the
parts of the trailer that let the scenes
play out felt very serious and very
horror movie like this felt like a
trailer that they slapped a bunch of
happy stuff on top yeah yeah because
when it gets all fun and upbeat and a
little bit whimsical with its tone
they're not letting scenes play out it's
just like it's very editorial Rainn
Wilson in here whatever it's surprising
there's like a lack of Jason Statham in
this trailer who's the lead of it
because the scenes that play out feel
like a horror movie and maybe this movie
might reach that good b-movie hybrid
when it's supposed to be scary and
intense they do a good job with that and
the rest of the time is just kind of
corny and silly as I'm cool with that I
would like it if they could reach that
tone this trailer to me just didn't look
like it was gonna though I don't know
man I'm gonna give it a chance
regardless I hope it's it's fun I'm not
against what this trailer wants to sell
me but I just don't buy it dude I smell
the franchise man aha
supera croc and then he takes on the an
anaconda finally man movies will break
out of their sci-fi channel prison onto
the bigs a theater near yeah but that
first shot though the little asian girl
the dawn that was pretty scary at that
that threw me for a loop cuz I thought
I'd just be laughing this whole trailer
when you see that giant of teeth and
they sink into the glass like wow that
that would actually be a terrifying
scenario to be a part of plus we're
gonna get a like a massive ass squid too
so
oh yeah no this is a pneumatic unit
we've got in shark movies now we've got
a monster movies we got a whole bunch of
crazy mayhem coming our way and
hopefully Jason Statham could punch that
shark in the face you know who else
could punch that shark in the face is
Ray JT the man from Hawaii JT we had to
make sure to shout you out for this
because you live near the waters my
friend and if there's anyone out there
who could protect the people of Hawaii
from a giant Megalodon it's you you know
why not with your fists with your stare
with your calming and your calming you
would be way how kylo Ren versed Luke in
the last Jedi is how you would be
against a Megalodon in the water right
you just walk out there so it you would
intimidate the hell out of that
Megalodon because even though you are
one of the nicest people we know when
you're just looking at us talk I'm a
little terrified and you can do the same
thing to Meg we love you take care of
your parents for us because they seem
like good people whenever they appear in
the background of our Google Hangouts
all right guys we can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
both the subscribe buttons mean
something and check us out on patreon
full blank TV show reactions weekly q
and A's music video reactions to bunch
of goodies below to have you